tonight we set up several scenarios for
you yeah well I for a minute I thought
this is the 1970s game show
but now you've set up scenarios to take
you out of your comfort zone and into a
discomfort zone okay so that we can see
what you're actually made of okay okay
okay so let's start off with the
vulnerable situation okay usually let's
start off with a grocery bag here so
let's say thank you well we're off the
most vulnerable
I love the groceries you picked out okay
sorry go ahead okay so now so now we're
you pretend you just come back from the
grocery store okay going to your car to
put the groceries away okay you're in
your relaxed state right unsuspecting my
car we got it that's your car okay okay
I just like to watch you and see right
it's 1975 okay very good so I just like
to watch you and see what you do and see
if you make any mistakes along the way
okay I'm I'm alone I'm vulnerable mm-hmm
it's dark out I'm walking to my car
[Applause]
[Music]
let me okay okay okay all right
so let me tell you what you did wrong
what'd I do wrong nothing I had no time
first of all I don't do my own shopping
it's been a long time
anywho that was incredible
so first problem yeah your your head was
not on a swivel meaning you were not
aware of your surroundings wasn't aware
who Eddie's then when the guy grabbed me
I totally I didn't what to do froze and
he had way too many groceries in your
hand okay okay okay so so important rule
for self-defense buy less at the grocery
store well just make sure your hands are
free oh you're aware if not at least
you're looking around
okay I'll be looking around it so let's
try it again but this time when you feel
that when you feel the dump
okay okay I'm trying to warm you up
you're expecting it now it's no good
anyway there's no time for that okay
okay so when you feel when you feel
[Applause]
kiss you again this is crazy
but when you feel the gunk control at
this time and use it to your advantage
to gain extra power and and you know
extra focus okay try to guess right one
more time walking to the car let's give
you some alright walking to the car all
right I got yes let's go to the bag okay
okay I got rid of the bag I'm walking to
the car
[Applause]
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please